bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte le
golfe du saint laurent est un immense
garde manger qui nous réserve bien des
surprises
dernièrement une espèce émergentes fait
de plus en plus parler d'elle une espèce
à très haute valeur commerciale mais
qu'il faut aussi protéger
[Musique]
dans le port de cloridorme un bateau de
pêche a fait son entrée
sa cargaison est exceptionnel
ses caleçons plein d'un étrange animal
capturé dans les eaux froides du golfe
du saint laurent
le concombre de mer qu'on nomme aussi
aux loups tuerie la pêche au concombre
de mer est assez récente au québec
cette espèce à une très forte valeur
commerciale sur les marchés asiatiques
où on lui prête des vertus
thérapeutiques et aphrodisiaque sur le
web un sac de 20 concombres de mer
déshydraté du canada se vend 165 dollars
c'est un peu plus de huit dollars la
pièce
les concombres fraîchement sorti de
l'eau sont amenés dans un camion
réfrigéré pour être ensuite transportés
à l'usiné de cloridorme à proximité du
quai
patrick denis et son équipe ne perdent
pas une seconde pour débuter la
transformation de cet animal à mon goût
c'est quelque chose qui se produit
la chaîne de transformation des
concombres de mer est complexe c'est que
les concombres doivent être déshydraté
[Musique]
on procède d'abord à leur avis et
rations vient ensuite un trempage
thermique
suivi d'une période de séchage
et d'un triage selon la qualité
à la fin du processus c'est l'emballage
avant l'expédition
à l'exception de quelques initiés le
concombre de mer n'est pas un produit
vedette dans nos assiettes nord
américaine
c'est pas très connu non plus les gens
c'est pas quelque chose qui cuisinait
rester amis on essaie de faire comme bon
mais pour l'instant c'est dingue la
clientèle asiatique
[Musique]
pour comprendre ce marché très lucratif
patrick denis s'est rendu en asie
moi j'ai été à deux reprises à bord pour
vraiment comment ça se passe ce marché
vraiment que les clients quels produits
des clients de moi qu'est ce qui se
passe au niveau la concurrence parce
qu'au québec on est les seuls à
l'international y en a beaucoup de
consommateurs
on a travaillé fort pour faire connaître
la part du tout hello les clients aiment
beaucoup la bo s'était produit
c'est considéré comme un produit de luxe
[Musique]
sublime uma minot gatier le concombre de
mer est à coup sûr étrange
[Musique]
ce n'est ni un poisson ni un crustacé
cet animal marin appartient à
l'embranchement des échinodermes ce
qu'ils ont fait un cousin des oursins et
des étoiles de mer c'est une créature
qui vit sur les fonds marins à peu près
partout sur la planète
chez nous on le retrouve le long des
côtes du pacifique et des provinces
maritimes ainsi que dans le
saint-laurent où il est longtemps passée
inaperçue
mais les choses changent depuis une
dizaine d'années pêches et océans canada
permet une pêche exploratoire au
concombre de mer en gaspésie et sur la
côte-nord à la drague ou en plongée
sous-marine 10 permis ont été octroyés
les données préliminaires pour 2019
indique que les pêcheurs avaient prélevé
près de 900 tonnes de concombres valeur
au débarquement
environ deux millions de dollars
avec une espèce qui rapporte autant pas
surprenant que les scientifiques se
soient mis au boulot pour mieux la
connaître et la protéger
[Musique]
à l'institut maurice lamontagne on veut
démasquer le concombre de mer
qui est il et comment peut-on
l'exploiter correctement
ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment développer
la pêche pour avoir une pêche durable
puis en structure protéger et à la
ressource pour les prochaines années
pour que mieux cibler les quatorze
savoir leur camp la saison pas et chute
idéal les défis des chercheurs sont
multiples oui on voit que lui
tentacules déployés c'est une pêche qui
nouvelle on a encore plus de
connaissances sur le confort mais une
chose français c'est que c'est une
espèce qui prévu l'érable le concombre
de mer et fragile sédentaires ils ne
bougent pas beaucoup sur les fonds
marins
c'est pas une bête comme les autres non
notre plus grand défi c'est vraiment
de bien comprendre qu'on a affaire à une
espèce d'une biologie très différentes
et des innovateurs dans les approches
qu'on fait en recherche
alors vous voyez si des concombres qui
sont en position naturelle comme on les
voit au fond de la mer aux fondateurs du
saint laurent qui sont allongés
plusieurs voleurs avec une sortie parce
qu'ils sont en train de manger dit
qu'ils vont se sentir capturés ils vont
se sentir en danger
ils vont enfin pris leurs tentacules à
l'intérieur de leur corps
parce que c'est la partie la plus
vulnérable son corps se remplit d'eau et
à mesure que je manipule la paroisse en
corse du si ce changement de forme
rapide représente la grande difficulté
pour les pêcheurs et les scientifiques
c'est qu'en gestion des pêches la
longueur de l'animal sert à départager
les spécimens ce qui rend l usine de
transformation est ce qu'on remet à
l'eau afin de leur permettre de se
reproduire alors ça devient un défi
d'avoir une taille réglementaire une
espèce dont la taille change
continuellement pour contourner ce
problème
les chercheurs s'intéressent aussi à la
détermination du sexe et de la maturité
sexuelle des olo tuerie
les résultats vont servir à développer
des protocoles standardisés pour aider
les pêcheurs à préserver les stocks de
concombres de mer
[Musique]
il reste encore certaines zones d'ombré
avant d'assurer une pêche durable
faire la lumière virginie roy a recréé
en laboratoire
l'habitat des concombres de mer dans le
saint laurent elle veut savoir à quel
moment de l'année où ils se reproduisent
on s'attendait probablement ce qu'est
une pente est effectivement la première
semaine de juin on est une ponte les
femelles et les mâles se sont le produit
et il ya même une fertilisation des
oeufs dans la salle du bassin de
l'institut
les conclusions de cette expérience vont
venir est formée en fait la gestion de
la pêche et les pêcheurs eux-mêmes afin
qu'ils puissent s'arrêter de pêcher
concombres de mer durant la période de
reproduction
[Musique]
difficile maintenant de se passer du
concombre de mer à chloride à la pâte en
deux mois c'est le moteur économique de
2 m2 loué c'est sûr que si on garde nos
justes au niveau emploi nous ici on a
une cinquantaine d'employés avant on
avait 25 employés
on n'en a pas beaucoup de monde au
niveau local c'est très précieux pour le
village
il est comme une autre
là aussi on a développé une expertise là
dedans aussi qu'au québec on est bon là
dedans on travaille et qu'on ça fait 7 1
qu'on travaille qu'on développe on
développe une expertise adler est une
mine d'or à cloridorme pêcheurs et
transformateurs espère que pêches et
océans canada permettra de passer
bientôt d'une pêche exploratoire à une
pêche commerciale ou concombre de mer
[Musique]
vous voulez commercial c'est sûr tout le
monde veut commercial la seule façon de
le faire c'est de cessieu qu'on fait
attention à toutes les autres sources
plus qu'un autre sociaux fait attention
que quand on veut moi ça serait durable
aussi longtemps la pression est
maintenant sur les scientifiques comme
cette espèce vaut son pesant d'or
ailleurs dans le monde il y a eu sur
pêche et les stocks se sont effondrés
dans certaines régions comme par exemple
en mer rouge dans l'océan indien et le
pacifique sud
c'est pour ça qu'avant d'autoriser la
pêche commerciale dans le saint laurent
les scientifiques vont s'assurer que
tous les aspects de la question ont bien
été analysés je pense que la première
étape ça va être vraiment d'avoir notre
évaluation de stocks qui est prévu pour
voir début 2020 dont cali vers 2020 mais
assez certainement quelque chose qui
pourrait être envisageable à court terme
[Musique]
peu importe le scénario choisi le canada
restera encore un marché secondaire pour
les concombres de mer du salon cette
ressource précieuse pêché est transformé
chez nous va continuer de prendre le
chemin de l'exportation au grand plaisir
des gaspésiens
c'est sûr qu'on est fier d'avoir un
produit guyenne la gaspésie est
commercialisée en chine puis un peu
partout avant de revendre sa ses succès
c'est une serveuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]